dr. [ __ ] strange normally the couch
that I sit on allows less reverb less
echo when I film these videos but today
I was like you know what I just love
this movie so much I think I'm gonna
stand for this review the set normally
ends right here when I have the couch so
up here there's nothing so I put a green
screen a little Doctor Strange poster in
the background for it ruining the
illusion okay Wow
this film was something amazing I really
really really enjoyed this film normally
when I do reviews I have notes I have
like bullet points that I want to cover
before I start talking kind of just
winging this one because there's so much
in this film that I'm like I'm just
gonna talk about what I loved and I'm
like the few critical analysis negative
things I guess so Doctor Strange review
time to do this holy [ __ ] I love love
loved watching this movie Marvel who are
you who are you people
you guys are so imaginative and you keep
defying studio expectations of things
like in terms of a studio film like this
film is [ __ ] trippy this film is
[ __ ] weird there's a lot of weird
it's called Doctor Strange and it's a
very strange film at time mister
basically some of my experience of
watching this film when the movie was
done I didn't really have any complaints
or negative critical analysis or
whatever until I reflected on the phone
because during the film I was just so
into it I was just having such a good
time and I was loving the crazy visual
ass because the crazy visuals are such
an integral part to making this story of
work and what I'll tell you is this the
trailers they don't show you like 90% of
the weird [ __ ] that goes on into this
movie I love that because you know when
you see the trailers you're just
thinking of [ __ ] like that kind of looks
like inception come looks like a matrix
it goes way to its own unique territory
way dear friend way more psychedelic and
trippy I loved it I loved loved loved it
especially watching out IMAX one of the
few
films in 3d that I would say is
absolutely worth watching in 3d I got
caught up in traffic on the way home so
I listened to like a [ __ ] and I'm like
critics just I like to hear like the few
people like then check out consistently
or like the schmoes Jeremy Jones Chris
Stockman flick pick black and red comedy
you know the big ones so I check those
guys out I believe it was Stockman who I
recall him saying how the film the first
act is feels a little bit clunky and it
feels like it moves a little bit fast
and I agree from from an analysis point
of view in terms of writing and tone and
you know smoothing things out editing I
can see that for sure but what I will
say is that that first act still
features a lot of great moments and even
a couple of really great moving scenes
you know like I love the moment where we
meet dr. strange doing surgery and he's
bobbing his head to some seventies music
and he knows like the year the songs
came out he's having a little like
trivia debate about release dates on the
song speaking of which I'm supposed to
be going back on the movie trivia Schmo
down really soon got an email from
Kristian harloff keep a lookout for when
that comes up benedict cumberbatch holy
[ __ ] man I don't know how this guy
consistently just keeps showing how cool
of a [ __ ] actor this guy is every
single role I've seen him in he is
awesome even if he doesn't even have
much in a movie he's still really cool
yeah there's like similarities to the
Stephen strange character that are kind
of like people that we've seen before
like Tony Stark a lot of people I know
are drawing comparisons to him cuz dr.
strange is someone who is very
narcissistic very sarcastic emotionally
closed off egotistical kind of demeaning
to other people I saw this one with
Andrew from the movie sports channel and
when the movie was done you'd want to
see an Avengers of infinity war rocket
racoon star-lord
Iron Man and Doctor Strange all
bantering with each other because yeah
they they're all sarcastic egotistical
emotionally closed off [ __ ] in a lot
of ways that are also very lovable
because they're [ __ ] hilarious and
that is [ __ ] strange but Benedict
Cumberbatch still makes it his own I'm
so used to hearing Benedict
Cumberbatch's British voice that it was
interesting like quickly adjusting to
his American accent
I think he has a really cool American
accent I think he sounds [ __ ] sexy
what basically happens is dr. strange is
a surgeon he's like one of the best
surgeons into the world and then he gets
in a terrible car accident that causes
him to like lose a lot of the he gets a
lot of nerve damage in his hands so he
couldn't use his hands but he's
constantly shaking so he can't really do
surgery with a guy who has like really
fucked-up hands and it's driving him
insane in the first act and that and
what I mean by how this film that even
though it kind of goes a little fast
through it there's a great scene where
dr. strange is having this like
breakdown in front of Rachel McAdams
he's taking out a lot of [ __ ] on her and
it's a felt like a real sample like this
would be a real argument and this felt
like real like [ __ ] up tactics a guy
does to someone that he loves yo cat I'm
filming why do you only make this kind
of noise when I'm filming already got
all this echo in here I gotta worry
about there's enough to make me get into
the moment to be like damn I I really do
want to see this guy go through all the
magic stuff now because I feel for him I
feel really bad for this guy when he
does travel to India to start looking
for you know Eastern kind of treatment
it was interesting you know this is a
real fish out of water kind of tail and
things really do it like I completely
agree with stuff like things really do
begin to smooth out when he does meet
the ancient one when he meets tilde
let's say about Tilda Swinton - like I
was one of those guys as a half Filipino
man I am taking a stand for Asian
American actors to be working more in
getting better roles of Hollywood Steven
Yeun Nightwing I was one of those people
who was like man I kind of suck so they
took the agent when it made her a white
lady I gotta say though Tilda Swinton
still owns this role and she's not
someone where it felt like her having a
be like an Asian kind of character felt
super necessary for this specific story
because it they established pretty early
on that she's someone who has a very
mysterious past and so she I didn't feel
like she had to be someone who's Asian
when I was watching the film and when I
loved it Tilda Swinton did was she
really gave it a three-dimensional
performance this easily could have been
someone who is yes like a the spiritual
wise philosophical teacher but she was
much more than that there was a there
was a complexity to her there was
complication her that
I felt she had this major depth the
whole time like she wasn't scary and
she's kind of intimidating but you love
her and you trust her and then her
scenes with her Benedict Cumberbatch
works so [ __ ] well together I gotta
tell you like when did like crazy trippy
[ __ ] starts like there's a cool prologue
that happens where you see visuals that
lie that you're like yeah I've seen some
of that in the trailers and there's
still awesome to see but when it gets to
like him
really beginning to learn about this
kind of stuff it was very very trippy
very weird and watching on IMAX 3d was
like whoa what the hell but I loved it I
[ __ ] loved how much they committed to
making it so [ __ ] strange like on a
personal note I am one of those guys
like a few years ago I was one of those
guys who discovered the secrets by
Rhonda Byrne which also led into a lot
more other forms of personal development
listening a lot of philosophical
speakers personal development
motivational Jim Rohn Les Brown reading
the secret I've read the power 2100
favorable I've got a lot of things then
listen to a plenty of audio so to see a
film where I'm like whoa a lot of that
kind of thinking that I've been taught
is being portrayed in a very physical
format and I'm like one thing that is
like straight out of something like the
secret is to the ancient one says at one
point is that thoughts become reality I
believe that that's what she says I'm
pretty sure that's exactly what she says
there's a lot of the teachings and the
trainings start with the power of belief
the power of believing in the power of
belief if that makes any sense
visualization is something that's so
important to the power of mental
training the power focused the power of
visualization so by someone who like
practices magic and stuff no I don't I
don't do that but what's really cool is
that a lot of this comes back to a lot
of things that I feel like especially in
Western culture lately in the past few
years ever since I think especially ever
since the secret came out how there's so
much emphasis on things such as law of
attraction and energy and how your
thoughts are energy and how energy is a
very physical thing in this world just
because we can't see it
doesn't mean it's not very physical and
very powerful and the most effective
thing in the world and I love seeing
this film go so literal with all that
happen it's like a big metaphor for a
lot of this kind of you know philosophy
and attitudes towards life and I gotta
say to Rachel McAdams man like she plays
like the love interest kind of character
but in one of these comic book films and
any kind of film like this love interest
character tends to be some was kind of
dull especially when they're not a
superhero themselves having her in this
film not only the Rachel McAdams make it
better the writing of her character was
well done where I was I loved her I like
love this moment I feel like she's
perfect for Doctor Strange even though
like yeah they have their things they're
gonna make them fight and bicker but you
can really feel a strong connection
between them and she kind of reminds me
of how they use Claire temple and the
MCU shows I mean if you watch the movie
you'll see how she kind of develops an
image it's sort of similar to the likes
of Claire temple it's cool having like
that kind of human character in such a
big film too like there were several
moments where she would like a lot of
her delivery a lot of her reactions to
things were really making the audience
laugh and you see that she is someone
who's very vital and important to dr.
Strange's life rachel mcadams if you're
watching this i love you
to prove to you how much I love you I'm
gonna reenact my favorite scene from the
notebook Cee it's like calm the guy from
12 years a slave said don't know how to
say what's he'll ever saw he's really
cool in the role he's like the side
mentor to dr. strange a person becomes
like a partner to him in the movie and I
really like seeing him in this last time
I saw him like rocking a sword and [ __ ]
was serenity so it's really cool to see
him like in this other big kind of
fantasy kind of film I really think like
ever since serenity he's greatly evolved
as an actor and this character in there
who guards the library of all the crazy
books I name Wong he's a big highlight
of the film for me to NASA Nicholson as
the villain I've noticed like even just
looking at Rotten Tomatoes consensus and
stuff that there is kind of like people
are pretty much saying that he is kind
of falling into the category of the
other MCU villains not being so great
and really the only issue that was with
the character that I think of why he's
not receiving that title is a great MCU
villain is because of the lack of time
you spend with him cuz in the scenes he
has he's great he's intimidating he is
threatening and mad snuggles and me he
pulls it off very well and he's really
cool to watch and he has some cool he
has like some really cool moments with
the visuals and stuff you don't really
spend that much time with the guy cuz
like in the prologue of the film it's
it's primarily his screen time but when
you get to like the later on in the film
it's usually like he's around when the
good guys are in the room too so he's
just plain bad guy role at the time I
feel like this film probably had in its
original strip that you do get to spend
more time really understanding his point
of view and why he's doing ways there
because either it doesn't have that much
springtime I still felt that like you
know what I actually get where this
villains coming from so yeah I
absolutely adored how crazy this song
got visually the film goes way above and
beyond with committing to its weirdness
of you know energy and space and time
like it gets [ __ ] trippy and I love
how much they committed to it they have
some crazy fight sequences where like
there was one fight that kind of made me
think of the frighteners that Peter
Jackson Michael J Fox Vil
so yeah well it takes inspiration from
like set pieces and actions
sequences or visual style from things
like The Matrix inception it still
creates a lot of its own things like 90%
I get why they wouldn't show in the
trailers and I feel like people might be
like what the [ __ ] is this film it works
so well in the movie but I could see how
in a trailer it might turn off like the
general audience the masses would be
like I don't know what the hell that's
it I feel like the reviews that you're
if you haven't seen the film I feel like
the reviews can be a little bit
confusing because a lot of the reviews
maybe make you kind of think like oh a
lot of cool visuals but the story seems
like a typical Marvel beachy and yes it
does follow a typical Marvel Beach heat
of an origin tale in a Marvel film but
one of the great things about it is that
this the crazy style is all a big
representation of the bigger themes of
its story because some reviews might
make you feel like the film has style
and then there's substance but the cool
thing about this film is that a lot of
its style is the film substance it's not
like you're just watching cool CGI when
that [ __ ] is happening it is affecting
you emotionally - it's more than just
wow that's cool to look at it's a
venturous it's fun it's breathtaking
it's a wild ride that films a [ __ ]
journey
Benedict Cumberbatch kills it as Doctor
Strange I am so excited he's in the MCU
I can't wait to see how this film
effects the future of the MCU I thought
it was a great great great time and I
really hope that if you haven't seen it
that you [ __ ] go watch it
and if you have seen it just comment and
tell me what the weirdest moment of the
film was for you so while editing this
video at 3:42 in the morning I realized
I forgot to include my rating system my
awesomely a rating system cuz viewers on
YouTube don't understand reviews unless
there's a rating system in there how can
you tell how I feel about the film it's
fantastic or amazing I guess in that
category I would include magical alright
rejects it for you the channel subscribe
and get accepted it's a quote one of my
favourite youtubers if you're like me
you've seen here you want to see more
click right here to see more oh [ __ ]